and then this booming voice comes out
the other end hello we have your people
we want $3 million by the end of the
week or they
die and then the line ends line cuts
[Music]
out I was a police officer was a career
detective in London at Scotland Yard for
16 years and I was involved in
counterterrorism operations and other
covert policing roles and then towards
the end of my career I got invited to
get involved in some kidnap for ransom
cases and then over the course of the
next few years I was exposed to a steady
stream of kidnappings across London most
kidnappings actually involve local
Nationals and it's only a small
percentage that involve expats
westerners or business Travelers uh and
it's rarely a case of in the wrong place
at the wrong time so basically it's
someone planning it well in advance
because they know that they're going to
get something out of it yeah if you
think about it actually taking somebody
off a street out of a car off a boat
somewhere and then taking them to a safe
location for weeks or months at a time
without being discovered actually takes
a lot of planning and preparation and
resources and so the kidnappers don't
want to do that with somebody uh who's
not going to be worth their while to
kidnap the people who will do the
kidnapping invariably are these gangs or
groups who see it as a good profitable
business model for them um very rarely
is it ideological and usually it just
comes down to one thing and that's
money can you talk us through a
negotiation case like for example what
has to be done first the first 20 24
hours of any kidnap negotiation is
crucial if we mess up the tempo or if we
if we get that wrong it's really
difficult to claw it back so one of the
very first things when I used to get the
phone call would be to speak to the
family or the
company and a find out what's happened
to see if we've actually heard from the
kidnappers and then I'd reassure them
give them some initial advice and tips
and if the kidnappers phone what we need
to say
and then we'd want to set up what we
call a crisis management team and this
is about getting the right people sat in
the right seats doing the right job when
the kidnappers do phone who are we going
to get to speak to them because I don't
necessarily want to get on the phone to
the kidnappers because that could
indicate that they've got professionals
involved and therefore increase the
perception of the value of the hostage
in their eyes and once we've done that
then we work out okay well what's what's
going to be our
objective on the first call and usually
it's
threefold first of all we want to
reassure the kidnappers that we take
them
seriously then we want to obtain a proof
of life we want to know that they've a
they've got the hostages but secondly
that the hostages are safe and well and
then thirdly on the on that first call
we want to set up what's called a call
Window because the last thing we want is
that phone to be switched on
247 because a wouldn't get any rest
spite the family's nerves would be shot
to pieces and actually we want to be
able to buy a sale some time to actually
get the money together as well and so
once we've done that then it simply
becomes a waiting
game but when that first phone call
comes in from the
kidnappers it's a pretty um it's a
two-sided coin in terms of it's great
that we've got the call but actually
just becomes very very real and usually
usually that call will be we've got your
people this is how much money we want
and actually here you go you can speak
to one of them
now in a hostage gting scenario is it if
they' gone for months is it less likely
that you that they're going to be back
the amount of time somebody is held
hostage isn't necessarily an indicator
as to
the chances of success it it depends on
a whole host of factors it depends on
where the hostage is being held and who
bu particularly if there's a political
angle to it because there could be more
than just a simple demand for money
there could be some kind of political
component to that so say for example
just generally speaking kidnappings in
Mexico or Latin America are pretty quick
whereas in Africa they could be weeks or
maybe a couple CP of months tops but
just the length of time someone's held
isn't necess an indicator as to their
successes are coming back or
not what was your hardest case or maybe
the case that kind of stuck in your mind
most a number of years ago I was sat in
an embassy
compound in a windowless room and about
a week before six people have been taken
off a ship and are now being held
hostage we so we thought we haven't
heard from the kidnappers at this point
and I'm sat at this table in front of me
there's a an old mobile
phone and I'm getting a bit nervous
because we should have heard by now in
this part of the world but I get up I go
make myself a coffee and as I'm pouring
it in walks this man mountain of a guy
and he shakes my hand and he says
morning Mr Scott why do the kidnappers
not
call and I turn around and say Mr John
they will call when they are ready we
must be patient and then we go and sit
down and it's as if the universe has
been listening because because right
then the phone rings and everybody jumps
including myself even though I've been
in those situations hundreds of times by
now and so Mr John looks at me and I'm
using Mr John as the communicator
because of the language barrier here but
he's been briefed he knows what he needs
to say and he presses the green accept
button hello my friend and then this
booming voice comes out the other end
hello we have your people we want $3
million by the end of the week or they
die and then the line ends line cuts out
and then I look up and all eyes on me
and this is the Moment of Truth this is
where all the preparation the planning
the negotiation strategies the emotional
regulation this is where it can
and so what happens is over the next few
weeks we enter into a negotiation with
the kidnappers and my aim is to bring
them down from the 3 million because
there's no way we're going to pay it a
physically the company didn't have the
money and secondly if we just paid that
money to the kidnappers they're going to
think well that was easy it's called
doubling thank you for the down payment
now we're ready to
renegotiate so we had to make sure they
the kidnappers felt there's no more
money
left and counterintuitively that
actually reduces the amount of time the
hostages are
held so anyway the negotiations carry on
for a few more
weeks but it's taking its toll on Mr
John and he's become a Broken Man and I
know this he hasn't shaved in days he
hasn't showered in even longer and I'm
sat next to him for 16 hours a
day and then on one day we'd actually
managed to get the kidnappers down to
about $500,000 at this point the phone
rings again Mr John answers it he knows
what the outcome is for the
call hello my friend yes how are you do
you have our
money please you must be patient this is
a lot of money we're a poor company we
need more
time and please look after my friends
they're your
responsibility and then this voice just
boomed out again no they're yours the
money in 24 hours or they will
die then again complete
silence that is until Mr John's fist
comes smashing down onto the wooden
table so I stand up and I step back as
he stands up and steps towards
me and says how can you just stand there
so cool and calm when my friends are
going to
die he storms out and literally for the
next 24 hours I need to work with him I
need to regulate his emotions I need to
validate where he's at and reassure him
we're doing everything we can to get his
friends back and he's the person that
can do that so we're get him back in 24
hours later he's suited and booted he's
out a shower he's out a shave he's a
brand new man so he sits down call comes
in and we get a deal for
$300,000 now we need to get
$300,000 in cash in a bag from one
country across the border to another
country out to where the kidnappers are
get the hostages back and everybody gets
home safely without being interdicted by
the local police or the military
attacked by rival gangs or or anything
else happening so we find a courier we
get the money into a bag and he starts
his
journey meanwhile the kidnappers are
phoning in every four hours wanting an
update four hours go by I don't hear
anything from The
Courier eight hours goes by I still
don't hear anything meanwhile the
kidnappers are losing it they're going
apoplectic they think we're trying to
rip them off we're trying to Ambush them
they're going to get arrested or killed
so I'm trying to reassure them praying
that the Courier gets in touch soon and
after 13 hours I get a phone
call and the Courier's been interdicted
by the local police who got wind of the
money on the
road and are now refusing to let him
go so again it's all about problem
solving and dealing with challenges when
they show up is who managed to fly a
tribal out of down speak to the local
chief of police who
releases the Cur and the money well most
of the
money and then I think great we can get
the Courier back on the road but he
wants nothing more to do with it and he
legs
it and again as you can imagine the
kidnappers now they think this is it
this they think it's game over and
there's literally mock executions in the
background on the phone
calls somehow we managed to find a
second Courier who is willing to take
the money he has to hire a boat go out
to a waypoint at Sea where another Bo
boat comes alongside him counts the
money five minutes later another boat
comes with the hostages that gets
transported back onto the Courier's boat
the kidnappers actually turned around to
The Courier and the hostages and said
right we're we're going to escort you
back to safety now and here is a clean
mobile phone that once you get
aore if you get threatened challenged
into any kind of trouble we will come
and help you out and get you back to
safety and why would they why would they
give the give them the clean phone and
kind of be so nice about the the
customer service that the quality
assurance by the kidnappers just made
good business sense for them because
these gangs these organizations they
don't do this as a one-off this is a
regular business model and they want
repeat business and the thread that runs
through all successful kidnap
negotiations is
trust it's and when you think about it
it's the most
unregulated dangerous industry in the
world yet it works 93% of the time
that's the success rate for negotiations
3% which just tells you that it that
it's about building trust with
kidnappers who we've got nothing in
common with are doing things illegally
and immoral yet without that trust on
both sides this doesn't
work did you ever have a negotiation
case where people actually didn't make
it touchwood every case that I was
involved in hostages came back every
time although I was aware of cases where
that wasn't the case particularly where
there was a terrorist
involvement and
often people won't come back they're
going to get killed by the terrorist to
prove a point either as a recruitment
tool or to demonstrate their capability
of doing that but in 99% of the
negotiations I was involved in it was a
criminal motive as opposed to terrorist
and it was a business
Transaction what do you think is the
best part of your
job the best part of what I
do is seeing the faces on the hostages
and the families when they're
reunited there's no greater satisfaction
knowing that I've played a small part in
that and essentially saving somebody's
life what is the worst part when it's a
long waiting game
we call it the crisis within the crisis
because about 80% of my time on a on a
case was spent managing my own side was
managing the client well not that was a
family or an
organization because if you think about
it you've got emotions egos internal
politics competing agendas all coming
into play there in what is for most of
them the most stressful highly charged
situation they'll ever face and so
actually being able to reassure people
communicate effectively and navigate all
those competing demands and challenges
on my own side actually required more
effort and focus than than dealing with
the
kidnappers overall how do you deal with
the kind of emotional psych
psychological pressure of work and how
do you stay calm Under
Pressure I'd say the number one skill of
all the top negotiators that I know
it's the ability to regulate
self-regulate their emotions and a
highly developed sensory accurity which
really is a bit like a radar or antenna
where you can very quickly tune into
your emotions and other people's and
then do something about it we call it
name it to tame it if I can identify and
call out any powerful emotions that I'm
feeling for example or the person I'm
negotiating with either on the other
side of the table or my own
team actually that just takes the sting
out of it it diffuses the situation and
allows us all to kind of move on with
the
communication they also bring more
curiosity than assumption to
conversations and
negotiations with zero judgment they can
park their own ego they really
interested in the other person they're
communicating with and over time they've
learned to be pretty unflappable they've
learned to more often than not come from
a place of
equinity and being grounded and calm at
a sent of the storm that's raging around
them it's every single day life will
present you with opportunities to
practice this stuff to practice the
techniques
of demonstrating empathy of validating
of truly listening at a deep level of
reassuring and paraphrasing and
summarizing and above all making the
other person you're speaking with
whether not it's a kidnapper your
teenage kids or your boss that they are
seen heard and
understood and the best negotiators in
my experience can do that but above that
I think reading people is a skill that
comes from bringing that Curiosity being
genuinely interested in people and over
time you notice similar patterns and
themes about if you can get below the
wants get below the demands and find out
what somebody's real human need is then
you can start to influence and persuade
and seek some kind of cooperation for
example if the kidnapper says I want $10
million on a fully fuel plane to get get
me out of the country that's their wants
that's their demands but they're not
going to get that what the needs are
that lie behind that they want to feel
special they're significant they want
some element of control they also want
to be reassured that they're not going
to get
hurt and they're going to be able to
walk away from this negotiation
regardless at the
end and I
think based on that actually spotting Li
Liars people who aren't telling the
truth is difficult because you do get
some very good liars so I think there's
two separate skill sets there spotting
Liars is one thing but actually learning
to read people generally is another so
my biggest piece of advice to people is
to truly listen remember the golden rule
of negotiation is it's not about
you and you got to First seek to
understand before being
understood
do you win all arguments in your
personal
life in my head I think I win all
arguments in my personal life the
reality is different I'm sure um and my
teenage kids have grown up um knowing
and seeing me do what I do for a living
and they've probably picked up every
trick and technique in the book so they
just played against me every single time
um and I'm sure my partner and friend
will probably say the
same and I'd also say is seek out worthy
opponents what I mean by that is seek
out those people and those situations
they're going to challenge you because
that's where you know you're getting
better and stronger and a more capable
and effective negotiator and also don't
be scared don't be frightened of making
mistakes it's just try one or two
techniques at a time and then over a
period of days weeks months or years is
you'll become the best negotiator you
can
[Music]
be can I make one request uh do you mind
though if you you I could be shot in the
head and they then discuss this and the
Müller another Muller was discussing and
they said yeah yeah
okay
uh you we're grant you that so then it's
like oh my God so I am being executed